what's up guys we're on Hollywood
Boulevard where Zack Evans will be
crossing over innocent people have you
found any cool restaurants you like to
go to you you just got crossed over
she's a strong defender first on that
defense I mean this is street ball but
she fouled she found me you saw let's
watch the replay let's watch the replay
right now that's a foul oh gosh you got
me right I think there's a little red
amount on right there so maybe save me
that work but it is illegal you can't do
that have you been in LA about 18 hours
look to me like you just got your ankles
broken well the camera didn't catch it
but I asked he duped him real quick and
then I went back to standing right here
but he said your game was weak how do
you feel about that I think the only
thing this week was his ankles cuz
homeboy got shook
he defended himself pretty well get that
cross over I will say in the beginning
that you broke those ankles somewhat you
know what I mean so what do what do you
think how do you feel about that he's
gonna need that ice and maybe some
surgery maybe even check his ACL because
I did that boy dirty good game do it
we're doing ok ok ok awesome all right
you just got crossover by that guy
Daniel do you have any final thoughts
words anything you'd like to say to
people shout out to my mom my family you
know what's your ideal like weather
temperature Oh like 75 accord that's not
fair cause Aaron it seems as I hope you
might have broken his ankles should we
call an ambulance or maybe just pick his
little floor back I'm done you're done
and don't worry well that's it for Zach
Evans we had a good run and it was a
good time we experimented and we
experienced ball being life here on
Hollywood Boulevard